in this series I'm gonna surprise you
I'm going to strip away all the
complexity and hard craft and teach you
how to cook amazing food standing on
your head that is amazing incredibly
tender from the kitchen novice to the
budding Chef I'm going to give you the
confidence the recipes and The Insider
knowledge to make you a much better cook
slicer out
wasting nothing
[Music]
I've been cooking in professional
kitchens for over 25 years so what
cheese is in the macaroni now I've been
taught by some of the best chefs in the
world and in turn I've taught some of
the best have his Whiskey's in there
a little bit now I'm going to show you
some simple and accessible recipes for
fantastic food that you can easily cook
at home
incredible I'll be holding you by the
hand it's getting better and better and
better teaching you everything from how
to cook with chili and spice to bacon
real fast food and my ultimate feast
recipes this is the only cooking course
you'll ever need
[Music]
Welcome to My ultimate cookery course
cooking tips information and 100 recipes
to take your life on
the frying pan is one of your best
friends it's so versatile in the kitchen
learning to use it with these is a must
and I'm going to show you how
first up my delicious pan-fried pork
chops with sweet and sour Peppers
whether it's in the restaurant or even
at home one of my golden rules for
producing fantastic food is learning to
cook with confidence this recipe is so
straightforward but tastes absolutely
amazing
panel get that nice and hot
you think of the sort of density of a
pork chop how it needs a little bit of
help
sweet and peppers go brilliantly well
first slice the peppers that's the flat
side of the pepper so stand it up trying
to slice a pepper on the side is a
nightmare there's the center
start off
it's almost like sort of peeling an
orange go all the way around
down
and look I see one
now place the pepper down three finger
rule one finger in front two behind
pinky holding it down thumb holding it
nice and flat the flatter the vegetables
the more confident you are when you
slice so
don't worry about the speed
just let the knife do the work
take your time
speed comes the most important thing
is to get your Technique right
onion
now sweet sour Peppers olive oil in
[Music]
I'm going to saute them which is just
the chef's term for shallow frying on a
high heat for maximum taste
[Music]
some salt and pepper add a tablespoon of
sugar sugar helps to break down the
peppers quicker but caramelize the
onions frying them in a frying pan
perfect that's one of the sort of basic
essential tools of any kitchen because
it's so multi-purpose great for sauteing
tossing great for cooking fresh on meat
push away and pull back push away and
pull back that hissing is something you
need to hear constantly because
the minute that's gone your peppers and
your onions start to boil and you really
want them to soak it
you now start to see it listening in a
way that it's starting to caramelize
Sugar's working beautifully
that's ready for the red wine vinegar
in
smells incredible it helps to stain the
peppers as well look at the glaze now
you can see the sugar
it's worked as magic turn down the gas
and add a couple of tablespoons of fresh
extra virgin olive oil
let them stew for two to three minutes
now I want to make the peppers nice and
light and sort of sweet aromatic just
roll the basil almost like a big cigar
slice
basil in
and then literally cook it out for 30
seconds I want them off
beautiful
okay pan back on
now the pork chops I want to make sure
they don't curl up in the pan they start
cutting up in the pan they're going to
cook unevenly a few simple cuts through
the Rhine means the chop stays flat and
Cooks evenly
Point The Knife Down
flip through just season them
beautifully
nice large shards of pepper punch that
through lightly guaranteed that's
seasoning
is going to stay there hot pan touch
garlic and touch of thyme
the garlic
take a couple of clothes
don't peel it don't chop it just knife
on
crush it
olive oil in just starting to smoke top
of the chop in
and lay away from me
it's nice
keep that heat in the pan put the garlic
in there early
a nice fragrant bunch of thyme see how
the pork is staying nice and flat turn
that over look at that beautiful
I want a little bit of thyme underneath
the
start squeezing that garlic out I want
the flavor coming out
butter in
10 slices of butter tilt the pan and
baste
so I'm sort of speeding up the cooking
process at the same time I'm keeping the
pork chop really nice and moist
and now look at the color of that butter
it's almost like sort of a nut brown
check the color on the other side
beautiful
when they're that thick
three and a half to four minutes each
side 30 seconds from now they're going
to be medium so I'm going to take them
out and let them rest
the secret to perfectly moist pork chops
is letting them rest almost as long as
they're cooked in the pan
a nice spoon
of these Peppers basil smells incredible
keep that garlic on there be generous
with that vinegar out for the peppers
because it really is incredible
do two things simple like that pork and
peppers
and your conference is going to shoot
through the roof a stunning pork chop
with sweet and sour Peppers
the frying pan is so simple but
incredibly useful with this one pan you
can make a million different dishes the
more you cook with your fine Pan the
more your confidence will grow here are
three of my favorite easy pan fried
dishes
thank you
first up pan-fried scallops with crunchy
apple salad
[Music]
frying pan smoking hot essential for
quick pan frying
add olive oil
then season scallops with salt and
pepper starting at the top put clockwise
into the pan so you know which one to
turn first
[Music]
scallops have firm white sweet flesh and
cook in minutes
[Applause]
[Music]
next salad Lamb's lettuce
sticks of Apple
[Music]
lemon zest and juice
[Applause]
[Music]
add olive oil then toss
[Music]
turn the scallops when golden going
clockwise around the pan
[Applause]
then squeeze in lemon juice and give the
pan a shake
finish with lemon zest
ready in under 10 minutes my first pan
fried dish scallops with crunchy apple
salad
my next super simple pan fried recipe is
chicken and chicory and Masala sauce
[Music]
season the chicken breasts
add to hot olive oil skin side down lay
away from you to stop it all splashing
slice chicory this versatile vegetable
can be red or white has a lovely bitter
taste and is great cooked all raw
crush a clove of garlic and add then
Springs up time
[Music]
when the chicken skin is crisp turn over
along with a chicory
for the sauce add Masala a sweet
fortified wine from Sicily
foreign
of chicken stock
to make the sauce wonderfully rich and
glossy add butter and simmer for 10
minutes
[Music]
plate up and spoon over the sauce
cooked in under 20 minutes chicken and
chicory in Masala sauce
[Music]
my final dish cooked in The Versatile
frying pan is
sea bream with tomato and Herb salsa
[Music]
fry fillets of Sebring skin side down in
hot olive oil
if they buckle up press gently down for
perfect even cooking then season
Sebring has firm white flesh perfect for
pan frying
next the salsa
heat olive oil
add half cherry tomatoes
pitted black olives
and season
[Music]
after a minute on a low heat add
coriander basil and lemon
[Music]
combine and leave to infuse
as the seed beam Cooks it goes opaque
when it's two-thirds from the top turn
over
[Music]
baste fry and it's done
[Music]
Sebring with tomato and Herb salsa ready
in under 15 minutes
one pan three simple impressive and
absolutely delicious dishes beautiful
coming up on my ultimate cookery course
along with 100 recipes to stay your life
on I'm going to give you 100 quick
cooking tips to make your life in the
kitchen easier
first up how to keep your knife Sharp
it's far harder working in the kitchen
with a blunt knife than it is with a
sharp knife the secret behind keeping a
sharp knife sharpen it before and every
time you use it first grip the steel
feel really comfortable about holding
the still imagine you're holding a
tennis racket or you're playing squash
you've got to be really comfortable with
it now 45 degrees confident grip
confident grip with a knife this is the
butt of the steel really important to
keep your fingers behind there you never
grip a steel with your fingers over that
because the knife comes back in you've
just lost a finger always grip behind
nice long strokes so we get the whole of
the blade
over Steel
stroke and we start from the bottom to
the top so there
cross there across slow Strokes over the
top of the steel and then come back
underneath
then back underneath
it is so dangerous working in the
kitchen with a blunt knife you can cause
so much damage working with a sharp
knife is 10 times quicker more efficient
now
that's ready to start chopping
stop your chopping board rocking or
slipping a great tip is to Simply wet a
kitchen cloth kitchen paper or tea towel
and place it underneath
now you can chop with confidence
my next top tip is get the most out of
your humble veg peeler
it's brilliant for slicing ultra thin
ribbons of veg perfect for Asian dishes
great for making long delicate parmesan
shavings to top soups and salads it also
makes wonderful chocolate curls
your pepper mill is more versatile than
you might think tighten the top screw to
get finely ground pepper ideal for Soups
and sauces
for general seasoning you want it medium
ground so set the screw in the middle
and loosen it right off for coarse
pepper perfect for steaks and fish
[Music]
peeling garlic for one clove simply bash
it with a back of a knife and the skin
comes off easily
for a whole head Crush separate into a
bowl
cover and shake hard for about 10
seconds
then simply pick out the peeled cloves
[Music]
this is my ultimate cookery course 100
recipes to stake your life on I'll be
showing you a roast chicken recipe to
die for hold the drum and slice straight
through
but first like any good Chef I'm always
looking to get great ingredients at the
right price my shopping Mantra is simple
first rely on your senses make sure
whatever you're buying it looks smells
and really feels good and if you get the
chance taste it before you buy it second
is to recognize that knowledge is
crucial the more you know about where
your ingredients come from and how they
produce the better so ask lots of
questions and learn
you're never too old to learn from
experts and when it comes to buying
great birds one person knows what to
look for is award-winning fifth
generation Master butcher Danny lidgate
poultry is a great meet because there's
many different types of birds it's worth
tasting the variation of flavors between
different first and first is massive
turkey is a great lean meat that's
available all year round not just for
Christmas anybody who's worried about
eating fatty Meats is a really healthy
flavoursome meal okay game birds people
don't try them often enough once they're
shots they're hung up for a little while
but a few days at least it means the
meat's going to be more tender it all
adds in flavor to the birds
we've got a wood pigeon and a red leg
Partridge both really good and cook
really quickly
when you're buying a chicken some of the
things to look out for is obviously the
smell
and when you're smelling a good quality
chicken you can tell the difference the
Skin's a nice white color and it smells
like a fresh chickeny smell
when you're buying from a good butcher
you'll find you tend to get the giblets
as well which is basically the neck and
other orgas this is great for making
gravy
once you have cooked it you can use all
the off cuts for other things stir fries
curries pasta dishes save the bones use
the bones for stocks and soups a really
packed full of flavor
and remember there are lots of different
breeds of chicken all have different
characteristics and flavors so shop
around and find the ones you love here
are three of my all-time favorites
the label onglay these come from an old
British breed they've got smaller
breasts but the meat's delicious
the black leg a fantastic French variety
succulent with bags of flavor and really
meaty thighs
and the police this is the Rolls-Royce
of chickens Rich gamey and delicious one
for special occasions
I think people should maybe try and buy
Less meat but aim for the best quality
you're only going to get out what you
put in by putting the best quality into
a dish you're going to get the best
results
no matter how season the chef you are
there are always new ingredients and
recipes to get fired up about
so if a tidal recipe is getting you down
spice it up with fresh ideas and flavors
this recipe is an old classic roast
chicken but with a simple twist it takes
on a new life and is guaranteed to
impress
one of the things I love about cooking
and that keeps me excited after 25 years
behind the stove is that there's always
something new to learn every day new
ingredients new techniques and new
cuisines
start off with the stuffing it's amazing
how exciting a stuffed roast chicken can
be because it keeps the chicken
incredibly moist and gives a delicious
texture inside the bird I'm going to
start off with cured chorizo this is a
traditional Spanish sausage and it's
garlicky spicy incredibly meaty
that gives a little bit of sort of
richness to the stuffing get a freezer
in
start cooking that down and getting all
those oils out
little touch the olive oil in there to
get it going right onions
chopped
add the onions to the chorizo and in a
matter of seconds they'll change color
as they soak up all the flavor that
lovely spiciness has been stolen from
that sausage and now the onions smell
incredible
garlic
garlic in fresh thyme just hold it down
and put your fingers on there and it's a
really nice way of taking off all those
nice fragrant little time flowers
you can hear it cracking in the
background
these are cannellini beans they're waxy
very soft and so delicious but very
dense but for stuffing they're so robust
nothing breaks down drain them off
in
they're going to take on all that juice
as well from this freezer I'm going to
season them now because they're very
dense so it needs some help
and that looks like it's a dish on its
own good enough to eat now
I want to sweeten things up a little bit
Tomatoes half dried
in
that sweetens up
the stuffing
beautiful
the stuffing's ready look at the color
everything
Spanish it looks delicious now
stuffing the chicken I like taking off
these little knuckles
as the chicken Cooks the skin stretches
over the bone you can get a really nice
drum and take off those little wing tips
as well
salt pepper
so important
now you're stuffing I want to go right
inside the chicken
push it down this really helps to cook
the bird evenly because you're pushing
out all the empty spaces in the carcass
and take a nice large Lemon push the
lemon in
pick up the parcel's nose pull the skin
over olive oil on top
sauce
pepper
a teaspoon of paprika
sprinkle it on and then get your hands
and sort of rub that in and see what the
paprika's doing to the chicken putting
this like sweet spicy marinade it's not
even roasted yet but it looks delicious
[Music]
400 ml white wine same quantity of water
that helps the chicken to steam
Chicken in
be generous with the time Sprigs
make sure the fall is folded tightly
around the roasting tray so the chicken
steams in the oven keeping it moist and
juicy
into the oven
[Music]
cook for one hour at 180 degrees with a
foil on nice take it out and remove the
full lid then give it another 30 minutes
to crisp up that skin
look at that
so important to make sure you take that
tinfoil off with half an hour to go
beautiful
Pierce that open
squeeze it in that delicious gravy mix
that into the tray
sieve that
that's a really nice fragrant lemony
spiced roasting juices to finish
before we cut up the chicken take out
amazing stuffing
[Music]
incredible I'd have that with chicken
over potatoes any day and then just get
your chicken roasting juices
now
cut the chicken up
hold the drum
and slice straight through
and there's that wonderful drum and the
thigh through the wishbone
off
slice with the point at an angle so you
can see the texture
of that amazing roast chicken
take my cooking juices I just want to
give a nice sort of lemony flavor
all over my chicken and there you go
a delicious very Charming stuffed roast
chicken
[Music]
Follow My ultimate cookery course
crammed with key lessons
top tips and 100 recipes to save your
life on and you'll literally be cooking
yourself into a better chef
many of these amazing recipes are on my
app please check out the app store for
details
go on get cooking
packed with cooking tips information and
100 recipes to stay in your life on
right now it's all about outstanding
brunches
I love brunch it's a great way of
relaxing with friends and family not
taking yourself or anything else too
seriously
and brunch dishes should reflect that
spicy sweet or savory Anything Goes
and one of my all-time favorites a dish
that always creates a stir is the daddy
of all brunches
steak sandwiches
[Music]
for me the secret of a great brunch is
fun and Casual fuss-free cooking and
everyone helping themselves
this is the ultimate steak sandwich
you want the Rolls-Royce of beef it has
to be fillet now season it beautifully
I like to open up the top of the pepper
mill to increase the size of the pepper
in the steak so it gives that bit of
heat
nice little chunks
you just roll now
nicely all the way around
slice the garlic
in half
pan nice and hot
olive oil in
hold the steak and just place it into
the pan don't drop it
at the front of the pan
we're going to till the pan forward to
cook the back of a steak dual purpose
now roll it back
and see it underneath next
my garlic and roast that garlic
thyme fry that time I want to hear it
we're not looking for a lot of color
because you're going to dry out the
fillet so just
one end
turn it back down and clear the other
end in
lift up your thyme place it on top of
the garlic
the lift up your fillet and sit that on
top
of your garlic butter in
take a spoon
tilt the pan gently lift up and baste
I've got that scented garlic
thyme flavor
steak is going to cook evenly because
it's sat on a little a little bit in the
oven for eight to ten minutes
[Music]
pan on
for the relish you think of a steak
sandwich you think of a sort of nice
heated tomato relish
to make the relish finely dice a red
onion three finger rule one in front two
behind
through
and chop
wow
next roughly chop a chili keeping the
seeds in for extra heat start off with
the olive oil
into a pan onions
chili
[Music]
generous with the olive oil
I want a nice sort of Rich silky relish
from the
biggest Tomatoes you can just use red
tomatoes but these yellow
and red make the perfect combination
now put your salt in
pepper and then roast those Tomatoes off
take a wooden spoon and just sort of
break them up
once the Skins blister the whole tomato
just starts to release all that really
nice sweet texture
little teaspoon of cherry vinegar gives
that nice acidic balance the sweetness
of the tomatoes turn down the gas and
just let them sort of Stew perfectly
now a steak sandwich would not be
complete unless it had the most amazing
mustard mayonnaise
simply add three tablespoons of
mayonnaise to three teaspoons of whole
grain mustard
[Music]
now I've got the relish almost down to
like a really nice jam now I want to
make that relish a little bit more
fragrant
some basil
slice it through
sprinkle that basil in there
[Music]
beautiful
look at this
there she is my crown jewels
time to take it out
smell is incredible
just based one more time
fill it
touches quite soft in the center so it's
just coming up to mid-rare let it rest
the same time you cooked it would be
nice and pink evenly throughout the
steak to make my sandwich I'm going to
char grill some sliced Jupiter bread
season it nicely
just a little drizzle of olive oil I
want to get that bread nice and crispy
pan nice and hot bread in push it down
smell is amazing that Char sort of
charcoal flavor we've got those marks on
the bread it's just stops the bread from
becoming soggy and look at this here
it is stunning
on
slice it
gently
one beautiful slice
wow
it's nice and pink all the way through
and the beef is so soft
it's almost like slicing through butter
let the knife do the work take a little
bit of mayonnaise spread that the back
of the spoon
on both sides next
lettuce
take that beautiful slice of beef well
and then relish
on top of that beef and just slice the
sandwich in half
beautiful
now that's what I call a steak sandwich
trust me so the sublime sandwich for
brunch and you'll put a smile on
everyone's face
next up my guide to buying the best beef
and steaks
the ultimate brunch you can't do any
better than start with a perfect steak
and one man who really knows his steak
is Master butcher Danny lidgate steak is
my favorite type of meat and I think
it's really good to enjoy different
varieties of steak when choosing a steak
that you want you need to look at
exactly what you want out of it for my
ultimate steak sandwich I used to fill
it because it's the most tender the
fillet does the least amount of work
than all the other mussels it's tucked
away in the rib cage this means that
when you're buying a fillet
it's incredibly soft like butter it's
the most expensive but you get what you
pay for
there's a wide array of cuts to choose
from all different in taste and texture
if in doubt ask your butcher
this would be the ramp section where the
rump comes from which is basically the
back side take the bone out and what
you're left with is a wonderful steak
rum steak characteristically a little
bit tougher than the sirloin or a little
bit chew it in the ribeye but a really
strong flavor for the steak again when
buying rum look for the marbling try and
get some fat covering on the steak you
can always cut it off after it's cooked
Rams one of the best value Stakes I love
it thinly cut and fresh fried in stir
fries or simply marinated and whacked on
the barbecue another great value but
delicious gut is the hanger steak known
as the butcher's cut because they often
keep it for themselves it's great
marinated and cooked quickly
with the sirloin which is basically the
back of the animal a nice sirloin like
this really well marbled don't buy too
lean so once the solo is trimmed up
it looks something like this not too
much fat but you need a little bit of
cooking it next to the sirloin is the
rib really popular now rib eyes small
nice really tender juicy steaks it's
really especially good for barbecuing or
grilling fantastic probably my favorite
steak would be a rib eye ribeye is
especially delicious because the
marbling in the meat loads it with
flavor for a full-on steak experience
try the T-bone steak with a small tender
fillet steak on one side of the bone and
a larger flavor some Sirloin on the
other
take your butcher's advice and you won't
go wrong the final word has to go to
Danny when buying meat knowledge really
is power so it's important to ask as
many questions about the meat you're
buying find out the breeds how it's aged
and decide exactly what you want to do
each particular job that should then
give you a really amazing end products
[Music]
the great thing about brunch is there
are no rules the only thing I insist on
are it's got to be fuss-free easy to
cook and so delicious it puts you in a
good mood for the rest of the day
and for me pancakes always hit the spot
here are three of my deliciously
different recipes certified to liven up
your mornings first up fluffy blueberry
and ricotta pancakes with yogurt
[Music]
start by adding 125 grams of plain flour
a teaspoon of baking powder
a pinch of salt a tablespoon of sugar
then create a wet in the center separate
two eggs and add the yolks keeping the
whites for later beat the yolks into the
flour pouring in milk gradually to form
a smooth batter
[Music]
next fold in 125 grams of creamy ricotta
cheese and 100 grams of fresh
blueberries
now whisk your egg whites into the
almost reached soft peaks
then gently fold into the pancake mix
keeping in the air to make sure the
pancakes are extra light and really
fluffy
add olive oil and butter into a hot pan
then spoon in the mix to make small
pancakes cooking until golden brown on
both sides
to finish top with Greek yogurt
fresh blueberries
and drizzle over lovely runny honey
sweet Savory fruity and delicious made
in 15 minutes perfect brunch pancakes
foreign
simple pancake brunch recipe is
n't crab and mascarpone crepes
[Music]
for the filling put cooked white crab
meat into a bowl add in mascarpone the
zest and juice of a lemon
finely chopped chives and for a spicy
hit cayenne pepper stir
set aside
for the pancake batter simply add flour
salt an egg and milk then whisk into a
smooth mixture
add oil to a hot nonstick pan Ladle in
batter to cover the bottom and swirl it
around spreading out nice and thinly
when lovely and golden flip over turn
out and Spoon the delicious crab mix
into the center of the pancake and roll
finally sprinkle with some chopped
chives and devour
my second pancake recipe grab a mask of
own Crepes a fantastic easy brunch
cooked in minutes
[Music]
when you want your pancakes sweet and
zingy this recipe is perfect
coconut pancakes with mango and lime
syrup
[Music]
for the lime syrup simply Add Water
caster sugar
possessed and juice of a lime and simmer
for 10 minutes
[Music]
to make the easy pancake batter put
flour baking powder and desiccated
coconut into a bowl then crack in an egg
add coconut milk
and whisk into the batter until well
combined
sweetened with runny honey
now you're ready to fry add melted
butter to a hot pan place in Heap
teaspoons of batter flip and cook until
golden for a lovely vibrant wake up
serve with sliced fresh mango and drill
over the gorgeous citrusy syrup Sweet
Sticky and utterly irresistible ready in
under 20 minutes the ultimate indulgent
pancakes
fast to prepare easy to make three
effortless recipes guaranteed to bring
some sparkle to your brunches incredible
welcome back to my ultimate cookery
course
I'm teaching you all about brunches the
most laid-back meal of the week and if
you want to take it easy having the
right equipment makes all the difference
[Music]
here's my guide to the best kitchen
equipment
[Music]
everything you need to know about the
basic kit that will get you cooking
fantastic food
chopping boards for brunch one of the
most useful things is a great chopping
board get the right one and it'll be
your friend for life
I prefer a sort of heavy duty one
because they're so much more durable
they can be flipped over the minute you
want to go from vegetables to prepping
fish or meat always keep a little Jake
off underneath that actually stops the
board from sliding care for your wooden
board by rubbing it with oil every so
often any cooking oil will do wooden
boards for me are always the best easy
to clean and long lasting when you do
wash your wooden board never let it
stand in water or put it in the
dishwasher as it may split buy the best
you can afford and take good care of it
[Music]
for brunch I love something sweet and
I've always been a fan of classic
British crumpets with butter and jam
but once you try cooking them at home
you'll never want to buy them from shops
again
this is another great recipe you can
stay your life on
it's my homemade crumpet
whether you're cooking for two three or
even a gang some of the best brunch
dishes are always the simplest these
crumpets are absolutely delicious and
it's a great end to a fantastic brunch
first off we're going to make the mix
what do you think of growing up
the smell and the taste of amazing
crumpet
it never leaves you
to make the mix the secret is to bring
the milk up the ball but do not boil it
the minute it boils turn it off and let
it sit there now
flowering
a nice pinch of salt in
now add half a teaspoon of bicarb that
gives it aeration and really lifts the
mixture up all those lovely little holes
a nice Pinch of Sugar
and then a teaspoon of yeast dry yeast
now once the milk's boiled turn it off
and add some warm water about 10
tablespoons 150 ml
that cools down the milk
but more importantly it doesn't destroy
the yeast half of the milk in first stop
and give that a really good mix
now the rest of it
[Music]
[Music]
you can just see that there's no lumps
through there as it drips through the
Whisk now we're looking for it to double
in size and get nice and light so pop in
a warm place whilst you get on with a
delicious topping
beautiful strawberries but caramelized
almost like a very quick strawberry jam
hang on
just
slice these in half
some sugar a couple of tablespoons
we're gonna take the sugar to a nice
light camera it's just starting to
change color now
turn the gas down and we're going to add
the strawberries
beautiful
just sweating the strawberries down
quickly and the caramel is breaking down
a wonderful glaze
on the strawberries
some lemon grated into the strawberries
gives it that kind of freshness that
really
starts to break down the strawberries
nice
up
smells incredible some lemon juice
a touch of balsamo vinegar
and that gives it a really nice
delicious tartness now
if it goes as the strawberries start to
cool down it will naturally thicken and
set beautifully
now for the crumpet
it's almost doubled in size but be very
careful you don't knock the ball because
it can sort of push out all that air
it's aerated as nice as light just see
the texture
she's ready to go did you boil it
here we go
instead of making normal small crumpets
I'm making a giant one ideal for sharing
now turn the gas down
you just start to see a traditional
Crumpet style cooking process we want
those nice tiny little holes on top and
that Crispy Crunchy base
right now it's time to add the butter
and just slide the butter
down the bag
that gives it a really nice nutty flavor
at the end
fish slice
slip beautiful
take that out
[Music]
Jam
spoon it over the secret is for the
juice to sort of run inside all those
little holes
think of that tartness of the
balsamic vinegar the strawberries
beautifully soft
and almost pureed
rats
and that delicious
now finish that
with a nice ball of creme fresh let that
sit there and that is an amazing way of
finishing off a traditional brunch with
something sweet something delicious and
something you're dying to tuck into
[Music]
next my tricks the trade and kitchen
tips
fruit can be a great healthy option for
brunch and knowing how to get the best
out of it can make all the difference
first up how to peel and cut a mango the
easy way holding its stalk end up cut
either side of the stone cut all the way
into the flesh making squares without
cutting through the skin then turn it
inside out and carefully cut your pieces
off
foreign
tip to check if a pineapple is ripe is
to pull a leaf out from the top if it
comes away easily it's ripe and ready
for slicing
my tip to get the flesh out of a kiwi is
to Simply cut the fruit in half and
scoop out with a teaspoon
try it it really works
if you have fruit that's not perfectly
ripe the tip is to put a banana in a
paper bag then add your unripe fruit put
it in a dark place and the banana will
speed up the ripening process of the
other fruit
foreign
you can make a grapefruit puree to
accompany a brunch pancake or a crumpet
in a blender to clean it afterwards add
a cup of warm water and run the machine
for a few seconds empty out and simply
repeat with a drop of washing up Liquid
then rinse
[Music]
of course bursting with valuable lessons
top tips and 100 recipes to take your
life on and you'll literally be cooking
yourself into a better chef
many of these amazing recipes are on my
app please check out the app store for
details
go on get cooking